anyways so your book let me go through a
couple things with the book i looked at
so you you go through it you got
regulations you talk about under taxes
you talk about lobbyists you talk about
tesla dealership you talk about how
other dealers other car dealership and
lobbyists played a role to her tesla and
selling cars directly to the consumer
propaganda with the amount of websites
the federal government manages
congressmen in prison there was a
statistic you had in the book that
there's more congressmen in jail than
former mafia bosses let me say this one
more time there's more congressman
in jail than mafia bosses and then a few
other stats that will get involved as
well by the way yeah right so so tell me
what prompted you want to write this
book mafia democracy you know patrick
honestly i got seven kids six
grandchildren and i'm just you know
prior to the last
i would say 12 years i never was really
too much interested in politics
especially when i was on the street you
know we had a couple of politicians we
were dealing with and we did our thing
but i really started to pay attention
you know um in the in the obama years
and i am telling you
when i watch the movement i watch the
system i see how mob like that they're
acting very machiavelli and very mob
like i'll give you the the the one um
uh phrase from machiavelli he says he
was advising his prince you read the
book you know he's advising him how to
maintain control of his kingdom and he
tells the prince you can do anything you
need to do you can lie you can steal you
can cheat you can even kill
to maintain control that's the number
one thing but to the outside world you
must always appear to be honest upright
and have integrity
and that's our politicians today
that's it in a nutshell you know and i
say this too you got a friend you got a
spouse she lies to you one time he lies
to you one time okay you give him a pass
you work it out second time start to get
a little what's going on here third time
you're really annoyed fourth fifth sixth
time that's it it's over
these politicians make campaign promises
they get on on video the next day
they're lying to us and everybody say
well that's politics it's not politics
it's lying and it's lying to the
detriment of the people that elect them
in office to help them and to help this
country and i see it happening so much i
see this machiavellian attitude and
ideology coming out that i'm worried
about my kids and grandkids this is not
the same country that i grew up in it
really isn't and it's not the same you
know at one point in time democrats and
republicans you know there wasn't they
weren't too far apart you know they're
not too far apart now
it's like there's such a divide
and this country is going in such a
wrong direction i don't know what it's
going to look like in you know five six
seven eight ten years from now are you
really that concerned are you really
that deeply concerned i know you and i
have talked about it offline yes but to
the public that's not part of our
conversation are you really that deeply
concerned i really am i i really am
patrick as a matter of fact you know i
started writing this book five years ago
i was writing it for harper collins my
last publisher i get through four or
five chapters
and i did research and i started to talk
about politicians in jail and
regulations and all of that and i went
to my wife you know well cami and i said
you know what what do i need this for
i said i have no problems with the
government now these people are so
vengeful i've seen it all my life i said
i don't need to do this i go to harper
collins i gave him back my advance i
said i need to do this now
and i put it on his side
but the last couple of years what i'm
seeing is so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
you